all right gypsy
Gypsy oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
um Gautier Mississippi which is the
coast of Mississippi
tell me about your family
um
my mom got pregnant with me when she was
14.
and then she had me when she was 15.
um
I had a godmother at the time she was
the same age as my mom she was 15.
and she ended up babysitting me when I
was like two months old
and it just from there on my mom slowly
started leaving me with her more and
more and not coming back
um
my godmother ended up getting custody of
me when I was
10 9 or 10.
but my godmother was an addict she was a
crack kid
she did heroin
pain pills anything you can think of
but my mom my biological mom she wasn't
any better
um
when before she got custody me my
godmother
my mom would pop up back in my life
like
twice a year
and every time she would come and get me
like I would be kicking and screaming
and hollering and my godmother like
when I was with her we lived in a nice
house I had everything I wanted and then
I would go back to my mom's and I'd be
in the hood
um
like my mom I just hated being at her
house uh
I remember when I was like seven years
old we lived in the some Hood apartments
and
[Music]
it was me my two younger brothers and my
little sister my little sister was a
baby at the time and my mom would sleep
all day long she would black out the
entire house she wouldn't wake up till
night time
um my little sister would be in her crib
screaming and crying with rashes all
over her body
from sitting in her pee all day
um I would
I would have to like
you know how like The Pantry in the
kitchens they have like shelves they're
like all the way up to the ceiling I'd
have to like climb them and see what we
had to eat eat like raw Ramen noodles
and [ __ ]
um
and then my godmother would come and get
me and save the day but
she would always be [ __ ] up so
even though she I will say this even
though she was [ __ ] up all the time I
still looked at her like she was my
guardian angel like
but I would walk in sometimes in the
bathroom and she would be passed out on
the toilet from 12 a.m till 6 a.m when I
had to get up for school the next day
like
so it was kind of I mean
it wasn't the best environment with
either but
my God if it wasn't for my godmother I
honestly believe I wouldn't be alive
so it's a rough childhood yeah
how far is you in school huh how far did
you go in school I graduated high school
you did yeah
yeah yeah and what kind of work have you
done since then
um
when I graduated
I ended up marrying
my boyfriend at the time
and we had a baby
and I had like little jobs here and
there like serving I worked at a bank
for like a month
um
other than that I haven't really had a
real job besides stripping
you've been doing that for how long
um I'm 26 now I've been stripping since
I was 20.
at this point that's really all I know
and drugs have been a part of your life
as well or not
yeah
um
and it's crazy to me because you would
think
Me growing up seeing like even my
biological mom she did drugs too
she claims that she slept all day
because she had Mono but like [ __ ] I'm
not dumb
um she was doing coke and all that [ __ ]
drinking all the time
but um but you would think me seeing my
godmother
[ __ ] up all the time I always told
myself I will never I'll never smoke a
cigarette I'll never touch drugs I'll
never do this this this is this and then
when I was like 14 my biological mom I
had the flu
and she gave me some Lortabs and I ended
up really really liking them
and then
um
when I left on my own at about 17 uh
I started getting Lortabs off the street
but it wasn't like an addiction at that
point it was just every now and then and
then me and my husband started taking
them religiously and he
he always cheated on me
um
I can't even count on my hands and Toes
how many times he cheat on me but
um
he would uh put his hands on me and I
ended up leaving him and when I left him
he ended up putting me in the hospital
but I had nowhere to go when
I left him
because I didn't have anybody
um
my godmother was in jail like my whole
life she'd be in and out of rehabs
prison
um my mom
I never [ __ ] had her my siblings
there we don't have the same dad none of
us there's four of us with their
grandparents and Dad raised them
so we weren't really close growing up
either
but when I left my husband I ended up
getting in some trouble uh
I caught an armed robbery charge
I ended up homeless
living out my car at the time
and then one of my friends told me that
if I wanted to make a few extra dollars
I could come strip
and
that honestly I know people are going to
say I'm crazy but that honestly saved my
life I
I know I would probably be dead if it
wasn't for stripping
but
with stripping
came money and with money
came more drugs I could afford it so the
Percocets and Lortabs and pain pills
turned into heroin
and then um
I stayed on heroin for a couple years
foreign
foreign
no my um
so when I left my my ex-husband
I ended up literally like two days later
mind you I'd been with my ex-husband for
like five years he was all I knew at the
time
um I ended up meeting this guy that was
younger than me and I got with him
literally like a week after I left my
husband
and me and him
ended up getting trouble together doing
all that dumb [ __ ] but he's the one
that made me get off heroin
because uh after we got in trouble he
went to prison
and then when he got out he got bonded
out after like a year and a half and
he's the one that made me get off of it
he didn't really give me a choice
yeah it's a nice favor of them to do
it sucked because
I mean yeah it was nice but
he still is the reason I have a [ __ ]
felony right now so
do you have contact with your family
still anyone
um is your mom still around
I
my godmother
I call her my mom
I call my real mom about Mom or egg
donor
but my godmother she
got out of rehab
three years ago
and she's this is the first time in her
life that she's been clean
for years she's been to about 15 rehabs
um but this is the first time that she's
really got her [ __ ] together
so me and her we're in contact we have a
good relationship
um I love her
but my real mom she blocked me on
everything uh
she just now reached out to me about two
months ago on Facebook and
she
we talk but it's like forced you know
what I mean it's not genuine
like I feel
even though I have my godmother I love
her death and I do consider her my mom
but I just have so much resentment
towards my mom I just
I don't know I don't think it'll ever be
the same
which is crazy for me because
even though my godmother
wasn't the best parent
um
my mom like they're
when I think of my mom I think of
literally [ __ ] misery
because you gotta think I'm in second
grade and she's got
boyfriend after boyfriend beating her
ass beating my siblings ass
um my brothers
um
and she let this happen
she would
it would be 2 A.M on a school night I'm
in third fourth grade be 2 A.M on school
night I can hear him beating her ass in
the Next Room I'll run to the living
room my brother's already in the living
room because he's scared crying and him
and my mom come out the room and he's
choking her slamming her against the
wall there's blood trailing behind her
she's telling us to get in the car we
get in the car he starts running out the
door jumps on the hood we're driving
down the road with him on the [ __ ]
Hood I'm like trying to console my
little brother even though I'm just as
[ __ ] scared and then we end up going
to stay with like a relative for the
night like that was all the time any
time I was with my mom it was a new
boyfriend but same [ __ ] they'd end up
fighting he's beating her ass he's
hitting all of us and it's just the same
old [ __ ] my Mom has never changed
um she's got a man now that takes care
of her and he's got money but
she's still the same person
I mean
I don't think she'll ever change
has your life headed near the same chaos
and drama
not at the moment
um
I'm smiling but I'm serious
um I don't have any drama right now
but
um
I mean I still dance and stuff I mean
that's
Chaos on its own but it is tell me tell
me about working in a strip club
can you work in what part of the country
uh I dance in Florida I started out in
New Orleans Louisiana
um
I got
um
kicked out from some of the strip clubs
in New Orleans
and what do you get kicked out for
uh just dumb [ __ ] like fighting
with guests or fighting with other
strippers just literally dumb [ __ ]
um now I work in Florida
I actually like dancing
I know a lot of girls will say oh I wish
I could stop and
I just can't do it I like dancing
I don't I don't feel the need to stop at
the moment there's a lot of drugs in the
club oh yeah that's not attempting for
you
no because the majority of drugs in the
club is cocaine and I don't like uppers
so
not really tempting for me
and this is a topless club or a new
um I work at multiple some of them are
nude and but majority of them are just
topless
what's the difference between the two
topless
is pretty much
how it sounds you can only take your top
off I know I know that difference I'm
saying in terms of the clientele oh the
uh
the uh I know what you mean like the
atmosphere the atmosphere the two
different clubs
um I would say at the topless it's
there's a lot more
how do I explain more upscale
gentlemen I guess you could say because
like at the nude
you can tell that's literally just what
they're there for just to see a girl
busted open on stage you know what I
mean like not spending any [ __ ] money
they're just there to [ __ ] look get
some drinks and go but at the top list
like they actually want to get rooms
with you VIPs get lap dances and stuff
because it's it's more exciting
when you have more on you know what I
mean and they feel like I don't know I
don't know how to explain it like they
just feel like oh I want to see more of
her
so
there's opportunities to make more money
in the back rooms and yeah so thanks for
sure is that something you partake in
um
[Laughter]
extras but
but
um I don't do extras at the strip club
I'll get regulars and
like
if I ever if I'm ever like in a pickle
outside of the club or something and I
need money
I'll like text him and ask them to send
me money or
um
I'll send them like nudes or something
it's that they can buy so I'm not just
getting money for free you know what I
mean
um
but when I was
17
I'm not going to say her name but um
this girl that I had met at the time she
was 21.
um
me she kind of introduced me to tricks
I don't know if you know what tricks are
well of course you know what tricks are
but um she introduced to me to like what
tricks were
and
I would like go to
like say if there was like an event in
town or something I would like recruit
girls for her and like make it seem like
it was this lavish lifestyle like oh
yeah we're getting all this money and
like you can make this much and you'll
have this and cars and that I'm I'm
[ __ ] 17 I didn't even have that [ __ ]
so
she would like
she would like get men off Backpage
pretty much we're setting them up and
Robin I'm like she would set up an
appointment I guess you could call it at
a hotel with a man he would buy the
hotel and then I would go in there and
she would give me a purse
and I would put just like random [ __ ] in
the purse and once I got up there I
would get the money from him and I would
be like oh here hold my stuff real quick
my sister's in the car she needs gas
money
and then I'll just leave my [ __ ]
purse there and Rob his ass and leave
jump in the car we did that all the time
that was like my little introduction to
I guess escorting
so it's not really escorting it's more
robbing
but we were like we had girls that
worked with us that were actually
escorting I guess you could say we're
pimping them out
has working in clubs like this changed
the way you see men
absolutely
um a lot of these guys are married
hell yeah they're all [ __ ] married
um
her girlfriend's room I don't I honestly
okay
like high profile men
[ __ ] disgust me now because I've had
NFL players uh mayor Senators
um rappers country music artists all
kinds of people that you would think
would never
do this type of [ __ ] come in the club
and like ask me to [ __ ] piss in their
mouth or squeeze out my breast milk for
500 so they can drink it or [ __ ] on them
like just the craziest [ __ ]
but
it's like at the end of the day like you
have a whole [ __ ] family like they
even talk about their family they'll be
like oh I have to go to my son's soccer
game tomorrow because I coach like what
the [ __ ] are you doing in here so yeah I
definitely changed my view on men
um
at this point I feel like the men that
people
think are
how do I explain this
like
just regular ass guys that's that's what
I love just a regular ass boring man
interject here it's just a vouch for
some men not all men are like that
you're right you're right
but for the women that are watching this
and losing hope right there are guys
that are straighter there there is men
who are you know more high profiled that
they're not all like that but I'm saying
for the most part at the strip club yes
if you're walking into a strip club
right if they're walking in their period
girl something's wrong
thank you
and you're surrounded by girls that are
on drugs have you had
have you what have you seen with with
just the club in general with the drug
problem
oh
um
what percentage of the girls are using
okay say
on an average night I work with about 35
girls 35 girls at one Club yeah wow it's
a big Club
um I would say
about 20 of them do cocaine and they all
just go in the bathroom they'll say they
need a bathroom break
they don't do anything in the dressing
room because there's cameras
but yeah if you see a stripper heading
to the bathroom every hour that's why
tell me about Karma
you believe in karma
yes
absolutely how does karma play out in a
stripper's life
um
I don't want to say
like a stripper's life but just anybody
in general like
I know I've done some really [ __ ] up
[ __ ] some really [ __ ] up [ __ ]
and
it's definitely come back to haunt me
um
if you want to take it there and say
strippers in general like say
a man comes in and
you get a VIP with him and he's drunk
and I mean this happens all the time
they'll accidentally leave their wallet
on the couch or under the couch or
something and forget about it and walk
out well or you'll see it on the floor
and kick it under the couch so he just
forgets
and then you ended up taking his wallet
and then everything that's in his wallet
which most of the time is a lot of
[ __ ] money
um
I feel like that type of karma
definitely affects your job because
you'll come back
when you actually need money
and you're starving and you don't make
[ __ ] that night nothing absolutely
nothing and then you just sit there like
damn
all those times that I did that to that
man and this man and this man when I
really didn't [ __ ] need to
and now look at me
but yeah just in general
I've done so much shitty things to
people and I know it's it's come back to
haunt me you're justified by saying that
these guys deserve it for I used to
being there doing that I used to
um but at the end of the day
we're all human and we all do [ __ ]
that's
[ __ ] up you know what I mean like it
might be [ __ ] up that they have
families and come to the strip club and
do all that but
they might think I do something outside
of the strip club that's [ __ ] up you
know what I mean I mean we're all human
we all do dumb [ __ ] it's just different
you know is this a lonely lifestyle for
you
yeah
um
you would think not because I have men
constantly trying to talk to me and save
me and
but yeah and it's it gets depressing
very depressing
you're addicted to the fast money
yeah you couldn't do anything another
job could you I've tried
um I actually did makeup on the side I'm
a makeup artist on the side but um
the thought of getting a [ __ ] check
every two weeks and having to wait two
weeks for something I can make in one
[ __ ] night like literally disgust me
no absolutely not I'm not doing that
and at this point look at me I have
[ __ ] face tattoos I have a felony a
serious felony at that I can't even own
a [ __ ] gun what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do I can't even get a job at a [ __ ]
um convenience store they're scared I'm
gonna [ __ ] rob the place like what am
I gonna do
so
yeah
and I hate when people are like
well you're not going to be this pretty
forever or you're not a [ __ ] I work
with [ __ ] 50 year olds like what are
you talking about
that's what Botox is for
eign actually live all over again what
would you have done differently
um
Jesus
uh probably
I wouldn't have married my ex-husband
um
probably would have stayed in school
like college
um
I can't say I wouldn't have danced
I can't say that
um sounds like dancing is not
necessarily a big regret for you it
seems like you you're pretty comfortable
with that decision yeah
yeah I have people all the time
lecturing me it's good money
yeah
I mean I wouldn't keep doing it if it
wasn't so but you have your own
apartment you have a car something yeah
yeah not all sex workers can say that
right now
when I was on heroin
oh
I mean I would get a car and then sell
everything I [ __ ] had if I wasn't
making money at the club and then I
wouldn't be have [ __ ] I'd be homeless
sleeping in [ __ ] Casino garages like
sleeping on the beach at night because I
live on the coast sleeping on the beach
couch hopping
and then I'd get all this money and go
buy a car and just it was like a cycle
drugs change everything absolutely
and you know
this is gonna sound
I'm not trying to say this in like
I'm not saying this as in everybody
else's experience doesn't matter
but I will say most sex workers that
I've met
have had [ __ ] done to them as children
as have I
when I was seven years old I was
molested
but
I don't know why I've questioned this a
million times I feel like something is
seriously wrong with me I don't know if
I'm like a psychopath or what
but
that I don't even think about that
that like I can't sit here and like give
a sob story about that and say oh I was
molested when I was seven and it
affected me like this I don't even it
doesn't even cross my mind
this is just who you are this is
literally just who I am I'm not going to
sit here and say I'm a sex worker and
I'm addicted to this and this and this
because I was touched when I was little
and I went through this like this at
this point I just feel like it's just
who I am
you don't you don't feel like you have a
victim mentality
at all everything that's happened to me
I know it's happened because I chose to
do that I [ __ ] up
and you take responsibility for your
business absolutely going on in your
life yep that's great
what's your biggest regret
ever
have you been in love before
yeah
yeah I'm in love right now that's good
like real love the first time I've
experienced real life someone who hasn't
like put their hands on me or anything
um
Mr Pizza great
probably
asking my druggie boyfriend
years ago to stick a needle in my arm
it's probably my biggest regret because
now that I'm aware I'm an addict
I notice my attic behavior in everything
have you transferred it to other
parts of your life yeah instead of
heroin you know it's something else
um just like shopping gambling yeah like
the the dumbest [ __ ] like sometimes
it'll be food and it'll be a certain
type of food and then it'll be a drink
and then it'll be Vapes and then you
know what I mean it's like I'm never
just satisfied with anything
I hate that
and that might stem from what happened
to you when you were seven years old
that you don't know it because it's all
you've known to seven years old
right
like
like the drugs too like I can remember
when I was a kid my
I would find
like pins like the the body of a pin
like the the end of it would be taken
out so it would be hollowed out and my
my godmother would use that for a crack
pipe
and um
I remember I would open like kitchen
drawers
and I'd find like burnt spoons or like
the bathroom drawers there'd be burnt
spoons and she'd be asleep and we lived
with my grandpa at the time
and I remember like I didn't want her to
get in trouble even as a kid I feel like
I've never been a child I've always had
an adult mentality because even when I
was a kid I did adult things I never
wanted to be with kids I always wanted
to be with grown-ups which I was
um
I would find like her paraphernalia and
I would hide it because I didn't want
her to get in trouble like uh she would
ask me to pee and cups for her all the
time and I knew what it was for I wasn't
dumb I was seven years old and I knew
exactly what I was doing and I did it
for her because I never wanted her to
get in trouble or we'd be going down the
highway and she'd be falling asleep
and we'd be swerving all over the
highway and I knew if we were to get
pulled over she was going to go to jail
so I would make her pull over and I
would start driving at nine years old
so
drugs have really been literally a part
of my life since I can remember and it
hasn't been like serious to me I don't
know if it's like a defense mechanism or
what but like
I feel like I just don't let things
affect me like like other people say
they're affected by it you know what I
mean
like I see all these other stories and
they're like oh when I was a kid this
happened and this happened and that's
why I feel like I'm I am the way I am
now but like
I I don't feel like that
I don't know if I'm like a narcissist or
oh you're resilient I don't know you
gotta you don't seem unhappy
how would you describe yourself
emotionally
um are you depressed or angry or
anxious
I'm not
depressed to where I'm suicidal
but I'm definitely depressed I feel like
I'm more angry
then I
then I am depressed
um
this is like my first time I've ever
talked about some of this stuff
thank you
and there's way more
like in between all this that I haven't
discussed
but um
I definitely
bottle stuff up I'm not the type of
person that just
talks about things I don't like to talk
about things it makes me feel really
awkward
and showing emotion it makes me feel
awkward
you grew up in an environment that was
pretty chaotic
yeah
like even my mom like she'll joke around
my real mom
she used to joke around and be like
oh yeah you're like my mom we're like
sisters and that used to make me so mad
because like
why are you joking about like that's not
funny
like I feel like I've had to be
everybody's mom
my whole life even as a kid
like sometimes
I know I'm grown
but sometimes like I just want
like I just want to be like a kid for
like two seconds you know
like a real kid
you never got a chance to
but yeah
so
and I definitely
um
I could admit that eyelash out on people
that are like closest to me
when I shouldn't
like they'll do one little thing you
know what I mean and it'll just set me
off dear friends
um
that's a very um
let's just say I know a lot of people
but I don't have a lot of real friends
people say they're my friend but I don't
have a lot of real friends very few
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your life
if I could say one thing to everybody
it is you never know what somebody's
going through
just always be kind always because there
was
points in my life like even as a child
where I would just sit there and pray to
God to just let me die
because I didn't want to live anymore
and nobody knew that nobody
so
I don't care if somebody's smiling if
they're happy all the time if they're
always laughing joking around
just always be kind
it's definitely
it's the best piece of advice that's
great
all right Juicy thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome
thank you very much